Bonjour! Vous avez peut-être entendu parler
de cette ville de Syrie nommée Palmyre. Elle
est connue pour son site antique, classé
au patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO, mais
surtout et malheureusement pour les nombreuses
destructions qu'elle a subies en 2015 sous le
régime de DAESH. Mais pourquoi parler de Palmyre,
alors que ce n'est ni une femme ni le titre de
cet épisode? Tout simplement parce que la vie de
Zénobie, que je vais vous raconter tout de suite,
incarne LE moment de l'histoire où Palmyre
brilla bien au-delà de ses frontières et
s'imposa comme une puissance qui se
voulait l'égale de Rome. Rien que ça.
Zénobie naît à Palmyre vers 240 après J.C.
Son nom romain est Julia Aurelia Zenobia,
mais elle est aussi parfois nommée Septimia
Zenobia après son mariage. Sa famille porte des
noms araméens, mais il est possible que sa mère
soit originaire d'Égypte. Zénobie connaît ce pays,
sa langue et sa culture, et prétend descendre
de la lignée de Cléopâtre VII ainsi que de la
reine Didon de Carthage. L'Histoire d'Auguste
fait mention d'une déclaration impériale de 269
dans laquelle Zénobie qualifie Alexandrie
d’Égypte comme la cité de ses ancêtres.
Son père se nomme Julius Aurelius Zenobius,
signe qu'il possédait la citoyenneté romaine.
Il est issu d'une famille notable de la ville
et est nommé gouverneur de Palmyre en 229.
Zénobie est décrite comme belle et
intelligente, plus encore que Cléopâtre,
la référence de l'époque. L'auteur de l'Histoire
d'Auguste lui prête de nombreuses qualité:
celle d'être chaste, mais aussi
d'aimer chasser, monter à cheval,
de savoir diriger et prendre des décisions
avec tempérance... Lorsqu'elle devient reine,
elle n'hésite pas à accompagner ses troupes au
combat, à pieds ou à cheval. Cette description
dans l'Histoire d'Auguste n'est évidemment pas
à prendre au pied de la lettre, puisqu'elle
vise un intérêt politique et est rédigée par
une personne qui n'a vraisemblablement jamais
côtoyé la vraie Zénobie. Elle constitue cependant
l'une des principales sources sur cette période,
avec la Res Gestae d'Ammien Marcellin
et l'Histoire Nouvelle de Zosime.
En 251, Palmyre devient une principauté
vassale de Rome. Les dirigeants de la
ville sont également une famille de
citoyenneté romaine, et prennent le
nom inventé d' «exarque des Palmyréens».
Odainath, le prince qui nous intéresse,
a même été sénateur romain un petit moment.
La ville a une importance stratégique et
économique pour Rome, puisqu'elle se situe au
carrefour entre la Méditerranée et l'Asie et
contrôle donc pas mal de routes commerciales.
Zénobie épouse Septimus Odainath en 258. Il a
déjà un fils issu d'un premier mariage, Hairan,
et un second fils naît de leur union en 266.
À cette époque, l'empire romain va mal. Il
subit des invasions barbares sur le Rhin,
sur le Danube, et le long de l'Euphrate
par les Perses. Les empereurs romains se
succèdent sans succès et très peu meurent dans
leur lit. Faute de moyens ils se contentent de
défendre le front Danubien, pour protéger
l'Italie, et les autres provinces doivent
assurer leur défense elles-même. Certaines
régions se dotent alors d'un chef local,
comme la Gaule qui instaure une lignée d'empereurs
pendant dix ans non par sédition avec Rome mais
parce qu'il y a urgence à défendre la province.
Vers 260, l'empereur Valérien confie la défense
de la région à Odainath et lui demande de
marcher contre les Perses, ce qu'il fait
avec succès puisqu'il remporte une première
bataille contre eux en 261. À partir de là
il se proclame «grand vainqueur des Perses»,
«roi des rois», bref, il prend le melon mais
devient l'un des hommes les plus célèbres de son
époque. Ses victoires font de lui le maître de la
Syrie et de la Mésopotamie, toutes deux reprises
aux perses, et les cinq légions romaines de la
région se rallient à lui. Tout va pour le mieux,
Palmure retrouve sa sécurité et Odainath défend
l'empire contre les envahisseurs jusqu'en mer
noire. C'est là-bas qu'il est assassiné en 267,
ainsi que son beau-fils, par un proche qui
l'accuse de vouloir usurper le trône impérial.
Rien ne prouve que c'était le cas, Odainath n'a
par exemple jamais frappé de monnaie à son nom,
usurper trône n'était donc soit pas son intention
du tout, soit il n'en a pas eu le temps.
Au moment de son assassinat, Wahballat,
le fils d'Odainath et de Zénobie,
n'est âgé que d'un an. Zénobie hérite alors de
tout son royaume, de son armée et des fidèles
de son mari. Elle prend le titre de reine,
bien qu'il n'existe pas vraiment d'empire
de Palmyre, et de «mère du roi des rois».
Zénobie est un peu plus ambitieuse que son
mari. D'abord, durant trois ans, elle essaie
d'imposer son fils comme empereur d'Orient,
en reconnaissant que l'empereur d'Occident
conserverait un rang supérieur. Ça va. Elle fait
qualifier Wahballat d'empereur sur des bornes et
documents, ce qui constitue déjà un coup d'État,
mais continue de qualifier l'empereur d'Occident
d' «Auguste». Et non, c'est pas un clown.
Si vous connaissez un peu l'histoire de l'empire
romain, vous savez qu'il est effectivement
séparé en 285, soit quinze ans seulement
après la défaite de Zénobie. Car spoiler,
elle va perdre. Mais tout ça pour
dire que la division de l'empire
n'était pas une idée sortie de nulle part,
ni irréalisable. Il était même déjà arrivé
que l'Orient soit confié temporairement à
des hommes de confiance en temps de crise.
Bref, son royaume est reconnu par Rome
jusqu'à un certain point. Zénobie tient
sa cour à Palmyre et s'entoure de lettrés et
de philosophes, notamment Callinicos qui lui
dédie un livre où il la compare à Cléopâtre.
En 270, justement, elle conquiert l’Égypte et
expulse le préfet romain Tenagino Probus. Elle
le fait ensuite exécuter lorsqu'il tente de
reprendre le territoire. Elle se proclame alors
reine d'Égypte et impose un chantage à Rome,
puisqu'une grande partie des ressources et
des impôts de l'empire provient d'Égypte. À
partir de là elle frappe monnaie à son image
et à celle de son fils, fonde une ville,
ce qui est bien un truc de souverain, et
parle sur ses actes publics du «règle
commun de nos seigneurs Aurélien et Wahballat,
Augustes». Mais malgré tous ces appels du pied,
Aurélien ne répond toujours pas à cette demande de
partage. Du coup, elle décide de marcher sur Rome.
Encore une fois, l'idée qu'une famille
provinciale puisse prendre le pouvoir
à Rome n'est pas si folle. En
cette époque troublée, en plus,
tout peut arriver. L'Empire a déjà été dirigé par
un Libyen d'origine phénicienne, Septime Sévère,
et par le bien nommé Philippe l'Arabe vingt ans
avant Zénobie. Même l'empereur actuel, Aurélien,
était un militaire né paysan dans la région
du Danube. Niveau prestige, on a vu mieux.
L'armée de Palmyre se met donc en marche en
passant par l'Anatolie, dans le but d'atteindre
Rome et de réunifier l'Empire pour son fils.
Cependant Aurélien se met en route de son
côté aussi, avec l'armée du Danube, et rencontre
Zénobie vers Ankara. Il la refoule vers Antioche,
puis Émèse, assiège Palmyre et saccage la
ville. Zénobie cherche à fuir mais est livrée
à Aurélien par les Perses. Aurélien profite
aussi de cette période pour reprendre le
pouvoir en Gaule, l'intégrité de l'empire
est restaurée. Pour peu de temps, certes.
On ne sait pas comment meurt Wahballat, peut-être
pendant le trajet vers Rome. Zénobie y est emmenée
en tant qu'otage, et à partir de là les versions
divergent. Un auteur dit qu'elle meurt de maladie
ou se laisse mourir sur le bateau, un autre
raconte qu'elle est traînée dans le cortège
triomphal d'Aurélien, en 274, avant d'être
exécutée comme Vercingétorix. Un autre, enfin,
plus fantaisiste, prétend qu'elle est graciée
après le triomphe d'Aurélien, impressionné par
sa beauté. Il l'aurait envoyée finir sa vie
dans une villa de Tibur (aujourd'hui Tivoli),
où elle aurait épousé un sénateur romain. La fille
née de cette union aurait même épousé l'empereur
Aurélien, mais puisqu'il meurt assassiné en 275,
elle aurait été mariée trèèèès jeune. Au final,
rien n'indique quelle version de l'histoire
est la vraie. Ceux qui, au IVe siècle,
se prétendent encore descendants de Zénobie
ont toutes les chances de se rattacher à une
ascendance glorieuse mais imaginaire, tout
comme Zénobie le faisait avec Cléopâtre.
Après la chute de Zénobie, la ville de
Palmyre redevient une simple forteresse
contre les perses et disparaît de la
grande histoire. Le règne de Zénobie,
qui tente de s'imposer face à l'empire romain,
nous rappelle celui de Boudicca dont j'avais parlé
dans mon tout premier Gentes Dames Badass. Et je
vous reparlerai d'elle plus en profondeur un jour,
d'ailleurs. Comme elle, Zénobie tente
d'asseoir sa légitimité face à un empire
parfois incompétent voire abusif mais échoue dans
son entreprise. Zénobie est célébrée en peinture,
à l'opéra, et devient même avec Palmyre
un prénom en vogue au XIXe siècle.
Voilà, j'espère que cet épisode vous a plu. Si
vous voulez en savoir plus sur Zénobie et sur
Palmyre, je peux vous recommander en lecture assez
accessible et agréable le livre Palmyre, de Paul
Veyne, écrit après la destruction du site antique
en 2015. D'autres sources sont citées dans la
description si vous voulez aller plus loin.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo vous pouvez
écrire Wahballat Auguste en commentaire
pour montrer votre soutien à Zénobie,
ça lui fera très plaisir. Je crois.Désolé
aussi pour le long temps sans épisode,
la chaîne a été un peu à l'arrêt pendant
quelques mois mais j'étais en pleine
pré-production puis tournage de la saison
2 de ma web-série, Time Warp. Le tournage
s'est déroulé fin juillet-début août, s'est
suuuper bien passé et j'ai très hâte que vous
voyiez le résultat. En 2022, du coup. En
attendant, si vous ne l'avez jamais vue,
vous pouvez toujours regarder la saison 1 ou vous
replonger dans d'autres Gentes Dames Badass!
Merci d'être toujours là et à
bientôt pour du Chroniques de Prof!